Welcome back everyone marvel has been filming its
secret invasion event series and samuel l jackson
has been talking up a storm dropping all kinds
of announcements about secret invasion and about
marvel phase four in the future of the avengers
just in general so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel we're doing a
giveaway for disney plus memberships because moon
knight is getting started next week i will be
doing videos for all the episodes just like all
the other disney plus series all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and post all your secret
invasion predictions on the video the name secret
invasion raises a bunch of eyes because in the
comics it was a huge event that came as sort of a
one two three four punch during marvel's big era
of event comics it was civil war the end of that
destabilized the entire planet leaving it ripe for
takeover after which the skrulls invaded and mass
duplicating every avengers superhero you've ever
heard of it was norman osborne who took credit for
cleaning up that mess killing the skrull empress
paving the way for dark rain when norman osborne
replaced tony stark and nick fury as the end-all
be-all of earth-based security after which
the real avengers got rid of him but further
destabilizing earth leading to the invasion of
asgard on earth like we've seen asgard on earth in
the mcu in an event called the heroic age which
served as sort of a rebirth for marvel comics
so secret invasion is a big deal but in the mcu
as you can see they've tuned it quite a bit nick
fury learned back during the 90s during the events
of the captain marvel movie that mcu skrulls were
mostly good characters which was a huge change to
their comic book mo and it was the pink-skinned
decree that looked like humans that were bad the
big announcement recently is that samuel l jackson
explained which marvel phase 4 movies nick fury's
going to cross over and why he's crossing over
and who emilia clarke is playing during the
secret invasion series and it is huge it is a
super deep cut from the classic secret invasion
run i'll start with the emelia clarke character
first because there's been so much footage of
her running around with maria hill nick fury and
talos' and it really is true versions of those
characters it's the real nick fury this time
real maria hill i'll get into the skrull fake
out versions in a second because that's sort of
a prelude to secret invasion the last couple of
years but reportedly emilia clarke is playing a
version of veranki the current skrull empress heir
to the throne of the skrull empire but here's the
thing it's a little different than it was in
the comics and it involves some different plot
we're at interested in the in the paranoia
political paranoia aspect of secret invasion and
of course it will tie into other things and and
and the skrulls in ways you haven't seen before
what he means when he says tying into things in
the future with the skrulls he's talking about
marvel phase four movies but also don cheadle's
war machine roadie and everett ross who's in
the black panther movies will also appear during
secret invasion because it sounds like the evil
skrulls that are taking over get their tendrils
into those areas of the world too so in the comics
secret invasion was this big crossover series
with the entire marvel line every single avenger
you've ever heard of was duplicated by a skrull so
like skrull iron man skrull thor skrull everybody
on the tv show they're using the secret invasion
series as sort of a prelude for the marvel phase
four movies so it's going to be a vastly tuned
down version of the comic book event series
in the comics the entire squirrel race was bent on
invading earth in order to attain an advantage in
its war against the cree race the illuminati that
we just saw in the doctor strange 2 trailer or a
version of them that we saw in the doctor strange
2 trailer visit the skrull emperor at the time
warn him against invading earth and the princess
at the time emilia clarke's character is banished
foretelling doom for their people big fantastic
four crossover i know everybody's waiting for
fantastic four in the mcu galactus destroys
the skrull throne world killing their emperor
making veranki the queen of the entire skrull race
they invade earth posing as different avengers
characters the whole tagline was who do you trust
because anybody you saw could be a skrull version
of a character in the mcu secret invasion is going
to be started by a different faction of dissident
skrulls who come from a different line than the
green skrulls that we've seen so far who've known
to be good we even saw a green skrull get arrested
by the tva on loki recently we don't really know
when he came from or what he was doing that
got him arrested but he did show up in the tva
emilia clarke's skrull empress character is
supposed to be in a relationship with the leader
of the dissident faction of skrulls and nick fury
talos maria hill the good skrulls have to stop the
bad ones from completely taking over the planet so
it's a little bit like comic book secret invasion
and the end goal is still the same and it's taking
place after a major event series now in the mcu
obviously the major events have been a little bit
different but avengers end game a major event that
made a bunch of avengers reconsider what they
were doing inside the mcu and some of them gave
their lives it's supposed to take place after the
events of doctor strange multiverse of madness
thor love and thunder spider-man no way
home hawkeye like if thor love and thunder
for instance takes place a little while after
doctor strange too this would also take place a
little while after that so a little bit by little
bit the mcu becomes more and more destabilized
leaving it more and more ripe for takeover on
earth and that's why you see so much footage
of emelia clarke running around with nick fury
and the others she's working with them instead
of against them like she was in the comics it's
a big twist on her comic book secret invasion arc
but that sets her up for a much bigger crossover
in the marvel phase 4 movies which is where we
thank samuel l jackson for running his mouth so
much about their movie plans nick fury said that
while they've been doing the secret invasion
episodes he's also been busy filming on two
other marvel phase four movies he's been filming
crossovers for amy and three quantum mania and
captain marvel 2 the marvels i'll talk about the
marvels because it's a little bit easier to thread
the skrull through line through that obviously
the secret invasion plot is spinning up to a
much bigger plot during the marvels movie because
there is the promise of intergalactic kree-skrull
war that's been going on for decades and if
you remember captain marvel during the shangxi
post-credits scene the joke about her always
ducking her calls not leaving her actual phone
number for the other avengers to use like the
hulk i'm so sorry i have to deal with this you can
get my number from bruce it was so nice to meet
you i don't have her number she does this a lot
welcome to the circus the real reason she's got
to leave the reason she's always been gone which
led us some drama on one division that they didn't
really get into but they will eventually get into
is that it's the cree skrull war that's been going
on for this past hundred years or so that's been
keeping her busy her being there for most of
this time kept most of the war contained to
that sector of space mostly but now in present
day it just threatens the rest of the galaxy
some of that will serve as plot for captain marvel
2. like the actual main plot will be a little bit
different but in the background you'll see a lot
of the cree skrull war getting ready to spill over
monica rambo will show up after that big wand
division post credit scene that was what that was
supposed to tease like nick fury was on his skrull
space station just hanging out after spider-man
no way home and the skrull pointed up she'll come
back in a new comic book costume with her full-on
spectrum powers i did a much bigger video about
how her powers work last year when one division
came out so i'll link that in the description
below but in the doctor strange multiverse of
madness trailer you may have spotted a really
mysterious looking captain marvel type of figure
we joke about how monica rambo is the first actual
female captain marvel like she became captain
marvel used the name long before carol danvers
ever used the captain marvel name well they're
actually playing a big joke on this with the
multiverse illuminati so working with that team
is a version of captain marvel from an alternate
universe who is maria rambo monica rambo's mother
who was just the test pilot on the day that
captain marvel got her powers instead of carol
danvers so that version will be more true to the
comics than the version that we've seen in the mcu
and they just dropped the trailer for the miss
marvel series i believe that she's using the nega
bands during that i think that's what most people
believe they were like a cree knockoff of the
quantum bands they're like a cree artifact that
transform energy allowing the user to manipulate
it like a green lantern would that's why you see
all the plasma looking energy constructs they said
they did that instead of making her an inhuman
so that they could make her powers a little bit
more like captain marvel's and monica rambos so
that will also get her tied up in what nick fury
is doing on his space station with the skrulls
and that'll lead to the marvel's movie the whole
idea with nick fury and ant-man 3 with kang the
conqueror is that my assumption is that he'll just
be a quick cameo scene or they're setting up some
young avengers storyline or a post-credits scene
for putting the new team of avengers together for
avengers 5. that'll be the first movie where we
actually see king the conqueror legit in the mcu
we got like a teaser for him at the end of the
loki series at the end of loki season 1 we'll
see him again during loki season 2 like he'll
be ruling over this version of the tva because
he's theoretically won the kang multiverse war
or he's in the middle of winning it but it sounds
like the events of loki season 2 that will deal
with that will take place after ant-man 3 quantum
mania the beauty they said with kang the conquer
is that we'll see many different kangs across the
multiverse in different shows and different movies
the version that we see in ant-man 3 quantum
mania will just be like the legit king the
conqueror that you remember from the comics we
have gotten a few teasers for that next avengers
team too avengers 5 or secret wars whatever they
want to call it they straight up welcome shangshi
to the team during that movie before they even
started talking about the nature of his alien
10 rings of power the whole idea is that during
marvel phase 4 multiverse is the operative word
but they are pushing things in a much more
cosmic territory which is part of the reason why
nick fury has been on his space station with the
skrulls since right after the events of avengers
end game the reason he didn't help out was that
he was busy preparing for the next big threat
from deep space which right now at this moment
is the evil skrull faction from the skrull empire
the whole thing with the cree sleeper cells
in spider-man far from home might also turn
into a thing but most reports have been hyping
the evil faction of skrulls as the ones behind
the secret evasion event in the mcu but if you
have any other questions about secret invasion in
the comics and how it's going to be different for
the tv show just leave them in the comments below
and we will get more footage later this year
big reminder moon knight episode 1 and episode
2 drop next week my videos for those will post
after they air be sure to enable alerts for my
channel so you don't miss any of those everyone
click here for that brand new doctor strange 2
trailer with new footage and click here for that
brand new moon knight episode 1 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!